moi
[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur france 24 36e
jour de conflit en ukraine et on va
s'interroger ce soir sur les buts de
guerre de vladimir poutine poutine
justifie son intervention en affirmant
qu'il veut des nazifié l'ukraine mais
son but ultime n'est-il pas finalement
de recréer la grande russie ou est ce
plutôt un rêve pour le chef du kremlin
voir une illusion cette guerre at elle
aussi des allures de guerre sainte alors
qu'elle est soutenue par le patriarche
kirill de moscou ou est ce plutôt une
guerre de civilisation contre l'occident
comme certains l'affirment la grande
russie rêve de poutine on en débat avec
mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés thierry wolton bonsoir
essayiste spécialiste des sociétés à
communiste et post communiste votre
dernier livre penser le communisme c'est
chez grasset bienvenue à vous en face de
vous et léna volochine notre
correspondante en russie bonsoir elena
également avec nous christian mas
carillon christian bonsoir chroniqueur
au point spécialiste des questions
internationales
et puis est avec nous au legs cops f
bonsoir professeur à l'american
university of ap rès attiré wolton je
vais commencer par vous parce que tu as
peu l'historien de ce plateau poutine
explique dans un article publié cet été
que craignent à et russes sont un même
peuple et que kiev est la mère de russie
le baptême du prince vladimir en 988
finalement ce serait une sorte de
matrice des nations slaves la grande la
russie la petite l'ukraine et la blanche
la biélorussie alors est-ce que
reconstruire sa grande russie et son but
ultime pourrait demander aux signaux la
france parle de reconstruire les rênes
au pire de charlemagne par exemple ça
c'est exactement à peu près dans le même
ordre d'idée puisqu'on est en lui sans
donc voilà alors évidemment je comprends
son objectif il veut faire croire que sa
légitimité de ceux de sa de sa guerre si
je puis dire enfin on sait très bien que
d'abord à ce moment là on pourrait dire
au site et polonais les lituaniens ont
des vues sur le tas cette grandeur ici
on débute sur le crès parce que excusez
moi mais la pologne et la lituanie ont
occupé très longtemps et une en pire
qu'on occupe et très longtemps cette
facette terre donc finalement chacun
peut éventuellement le problème de l'est
de l'ukraine ces cas surtout en terre du
milieu comme si je veux dire c'est comme
souvent donné dans les nations qui se
trouve en terre du milieu tout le monde
peut a envie de l'arrêt de la
revendiquer un peu si je puis dire donc
voilà c'est pour rennes se trouve
tiraillée dans son histoire hors de fait
l'ukraine et il ya une nation
ukrainienne ya une langue craignent
haine qui évidemment très proche de la
rue longue rue j'entends bien et donc à
une légitimité craignait si je puis dire
qu existe justement parce que vous êtes
d'origine ukrainienne
et russell brand russie
moi je pense justement je suis un bon
exemple des frontières poreuses parce
que je me sens à la fois russe est à la
fois ils craignent un
jeu je nuancerais ce que ce qu'a dit
monsieur wolton au nizan c'est quand
même il faut pas oublier que l'histoire
au moins de l'ukraine ce n'est pas comme
la corse où la bretagne par rapport à la
france ou même l'alsace et la lorraine
c'est plutôt comme lyon et marseille
c'est à dire que c'est quand même les
racines de la russie mais en attaquant
ce pays qui est soi-disant le sien alors
là de la dîmière poutine a créé la
nouvelle ukraine heure là ça y est il
n'y a plus de millage il existait
auparavant
elle existe en partie auparavant mais
avec beaucoup d'influencé russe beaucoup
d' influence polonaise aussi lituanienne
c'est vrai en fait c'est un c'etait un
[Musique]
comment dire c'était une
martine patte d'oie
un croisement de deux cultures un peu
aussi comme sarajevo par exemple la
bosnie herzégovine en ex yougoslavie
gelé dire mais là clairement
poutine en fait à créer la nation
ukrainienne ya c'est un grand moment
devrait lui décerner une médaille de peu
père de la nation ukrainienne a pour sûr
s'il y avait des doutes il est certain
que maintenant il ya une nation
ukrainien un peu comme la une nation
américaine s'est fondée en en 1775 1776
quand les britanniques ont commencé à
l'attaquer mais mais mais sans la
violence plus utilisent poutine contre
des vies qui en fait tu pouvais avoir
une identité russe comme valcke alors
maintenant on va dire clairement ses
actifs ce n'est plus rare que
les habitants de rack vont se sentir
maintenant clairement ukrainien même
s'ils se sentent et russes avant l'heure
ce qui monte quand même la médiocrité de
la pensée stratégique de pouce à vladmir
poutine christian vaquin vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
justement oleg cops f c'est une doctrine
finalement cette grande russie est une
idéologie c'est une idéologie qui a été
construite pièce par pièce et ça ne
relève pas du tout de vladimir poutine
ni même des soviets ça remonte à très
loin puisque c'est ivan iv dit yvan une
grosse ni ivan le terrible qui s'est
attribué le premier le titre de tsar de
toutes les russies les trois que vous
avez cités la grande c'est à dire la
moscovie étendue aux autres principauté
la petite c'est-à-dire l'ukraine et la
bière la blanche la biélorussie donc
depuis cette époque les tsars ne cesse
de justifier et les soviets ont repris
exactement la même idéologie et poutine
la perpétue
un pouvoir fort un pouvoir central qui
s'identifie dans sa gloire et dans sa
durée par l'accroissement territoriale
ou la maîtrise territoriale
donc il ya un rapport constant entre la
verticalité du pouvoir russe et
l'étendue territoriale le contrôle de
tout cela et poutine assume complètement
cette idéologie l'a appuyé par toute
sorte de relais dont l'église d'ailleurs
quand on va en parler en tout cas le
patriarcat de moscou mais ça n'est rien
d'autre qu'une idéologie
les dirigeants russes ont convaincu le
peuple russe que sans un dirigeant fort
cet ensemble territorial éclater que
donc arrive le temps des troubles ce qui
en russe on sonne de façon
particulièrement significative et que
donc si on veut éviter les troubles il
faut un pouvoir fort et cette
simplification de l'histoire
malheureusement est devenue une
idéologie qui a traversé les siècles
elena comment vous qui avez passé
tellement de temps en russie comment
perçoit-il d'ailleurs cette idée de
grande russie les russes alors je
voulais juste dire un mot des ukrainiens
si je peux me permettre parce que je
sais que vous êtes heures au conseil
craignant d'origine mais j'ai tilté
lorsque vous avez dit poutine a créé et
l'ukraine j'entends j'entends ce que
vous dites à savoir que poutine par son
attaque a obtenu exactement l inverse ce
qu'il voulait c'est à dire il a exacerbé
le nationalisme ukrainien mais en
réalité je pensé parce que j'ai aussi
beaucoup couvert ce conflit depuis
notamment 2014 et parlé aussi avec les
ukrainiens je pense que les ukrainiens
n'ont pas attendu vladimir poutine pour
avoir leur patriotisme leur nationalisme
et leurs idées nationales en réalité
depuis l'époque soviétique les ukrainien
essaye de s'émanciper de cette idée
impérialistes y compris soviétique à
l'époque que l'ukraine n'a donné qu'un
état satellite et
le nationalisme ukrainien est né pendant
leur lot de morts est née au moment où
staline a réprimé des millions
d'ukrainiens y compris ceux là aussi
amener à une collaboration avec les
nazis par défaut pour s'opposer à la
terreur stalinienne est en fait depuis
le
19e siècle en réalité les ukrainiens il
essaye de s'émanciper de cet
impérialisme russe qui veut leur dire
vous n'existez pas en tant qu'etat en
tant que nation vladimir poutine je
pense pour répondre à votre question est
réellement comme le disait m michel
eltchaninoff dans une guerre de
civilisation
est en général vladimir poutine ne
dévoile pas ses plans mais le 22 février
deux jours avant cet immense agression
de son état voisin il a prononcé un
discours véritablement historique
lorsque pour la première fois on l'a
entendu au delà des dogmes au delà de la
doctrine au delà de l'idéologie exposé
une vision sincère de comment il voit l'
empire russe et de comment il voit cet
état nation qu'est l'ukraine qui selon
lui n'a pas le droit d'exister parce que
la russie et s'il disait exactement cela
c'est la russie qui a créé et l'ukraine
lénine est un imbécile parce que il a
donné à l'ukraine la possibilité
d'anticiper de l'urss on aurait dû faire
comme staline faire juste un état
l'union soviétique aurait dû être un
seul état avec des régions autonomes et
puis j'ai peut-être une précision mais
les états rivaux le russe a ajouté ce
qui a été dit concernant la famine de
1932-33 qui a été à peu près 4 à 6
millions de morts grosso modo en même
temps que cette famille se tenait il ya
aussi une volonté d'éradiquer la culture
chrétienne et ça on l'a complètement
oublié donc ça veut dire qu'elle avait
vraiment il ne nous sommes sous staline
à l'époque il ya vraiment une culture à
treignac exister et à ce moment là ils
ont ils ont profité si vous voulez de ce
gigantesque drame pour occire éradiquer
la paix de la culture rényon essayer
d'intégrer le plus en plus l'ukraine à
l' empire soviétique est-ce qu
intéressant soudain j'ai vu le chiffre
en 1991 au moment où l'union soviétique
s'effondre le référendum en ukraine est
sans appel puisque 90% des ukrainiens
mais en 1991 disent oui à l'indépendance
et là effectivement l'ukraine met fin à
trois cent cinquante ans 2
d'union en fait entre cette cette union
soviétique dont qu'en fait l'ukraine et
la russie étaient dans cette union
soviétique donc il ya bien tout de même
eu un référendum ou à l'époque qui
disaient que les ukrainiens voulaient
cette indépendance donc il y avait une
identité chrétienne déjà
complexe et beaucoup beaucoup plus
complexe à mon avis que ce que j'entends
ce que j'entends autour de la table le
gros lot de morts c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que vouloir écraser la culture
ukrainienne
vraie crise en excuser moi c'est oui
c'est quand même la première chose oui
mais faut pas oublier qu'il ya aussi des
campagnes militaires de famine d'affamés
d'autres populations ailleurs je dis
bien je
sais ce que c'est uniquement contre les
ukrainiens n'ont venant de la part du
joueur j insiste alice et c'est plus
complexe moi moi jusque jeudi toujours à
propos du gros lot de morts si on
regarde la carte c'est là où l'armé
blanche à recruter aussi le plus de
soldats pour pour ses rangs d'une et
autres bars et 1 d une des régions aussi
ou de résistance religieuse par rapport
au pouvoir soviétique aussi enfin deux
par rapport à la culture à thé
soviétique donc il ya je crois il ya
aussi plusieurs couches de
disputes historique et culturel qui se
joue louche oui et ce qu'il faut dire
que pour aller à l'appui de ce que vous
dites c'est qu'il ya une grande
diversité de l'ukraine elle est au lit
gieux puisqu'il ya des catholiques à
l'ouest il ya non seulement une église
catholique mais 1 à 2 une toute petite
nn qui est plus importante des gréco
catholique et l'église rutten il ya ça
ça fait seulement 30% du peuple 70% et
orthodoxes mais à l'intérieur de
l'église orthodoxe il ya plusieurs
églises on va peut-être en parler et à
l'intérieur du pays il ya des parlers
j'ai pas d'idée langue mais départ les
différents et puis il ya des gens qui
sont et la russie s'appuie sur sa
russophone tout en étant ukrainien d'où
la vérité a dit poutine et la
constitution de la fédération de russie
dit que la russie est
susceptibles d'aller aider tout citoyen
russophone qui se trouvent hors du
territoire de la fédération
si il est considéré en danger la
constitution de la fédération de russie
s'est pas venir poutine lui-même sa
constitution qui datait d'avant lui
venir poutine précise que les
russophones peuvent être secourus ce qui
donne dans l'interprétation cette fois
deux poutine l'autorisation
constitutionnel dans de pénétrer dans le
dos de basse pour défendre les gens de
la république celle ci on est dans une
idéologie ben oui complètement parce que
l'interprétation pourrait être
complètement différente vous savez c'est
facile et un chiffre qu'il faut
mémoriser 25 millions de russes en une
nuit se retrouve en dehors de la
fédération de russie en 1991 par le fait
de la dissolution de l'urss c'est pour
ça que le 10 meilleures poutines appelle
ça la plus grande catastrophe de
l'histoire dans un discours le 25 mars
dernier en tout cas en pleine guerre en
ukraine va nuire poutine évoque aussi la
décadence de l'occident on écoute si
aujourd'hui il essaie d'annuler un pays
millénaires d'annuler notre peuple je
parle de la discrimination progressive
envers tout ce qui touche à la russie de
cette tendance qui se développe dans un
certain nombre d'états occidentaux nous
voilà que surya des offres de 9,9 il
affiche
on efface des affiches de concerts de
tchaïkovski chostakovitch armani nov
sont interdits les écrivains russes et
leur livre la dernière fois ce sont les
nazis en allemagne il y à près de 90 ans
qui ont mené une telle campagne de
destruction d'une culture indésirables
et le système guérini l'autre chose même
deux pour mieux on se souvient bien des
images des livres brûlés sur les places
publiques il est impossible d'imaginer
cela dans notre pays pauvres n'achètent
rien ni
révoltons intéressant là on parle
effectivement est ce que c'est de la
guerre civilisationnelle contre la
décadence de l'occident contre la cancel
culture parce que c'est le terme qu'il
utilise c'est oui mais et moi la mode ce
qui est très intéressant dans ce
discours ce qui me semble-t-il derklé
sur lequel il tient beaucoup et qui fait
tâche d'huile d'ailleurs un peu qui
marque les esprits ces trains des
modifications le prévenu nazisme c'est
très intéressant parce que ça donne dans
son idée est un genre dont bien sûr
rendre à sa tête ça donne une
justification de ce combat parce que le
nazisme tombés d'accord c'est léon c'est
l'horreur du 20e siècle donc si on va
liquider ce qui reste des nazis ce même
si personne n'y croit ça fait quand même
ça fait quand même si j'aurais
idéologiquement chic voilà ça tous les
sens ça fait sens exactement donc c'est
se placer dans cette perte écrit là est
un moyen pour lui de se blanchir
moralement si je puis dire oui personne
n'y croit évidemment j'entends bien
puisqu'en plus ce non seulement parce
que c'est un ski et juifs mais ça veut
rien dire oh toi mais bon il ya
évidemment alors je ne les réussis pas
me croire c'est ça en fait de propagande
mais alors une question sur les valeurs
morales conservatrice dont il parle
parce qu'il ya eu effectivement l'aide
de macifilia c'est très intéressant et
la conservation de ces valeurs morales
qu'on se remet très intéressant parce
que c'est cela dessus qu une partie de
l'extrême droite européenne et mondiale
d'ailleurs ce rallye africain s'est
rallié à poitiers c'est là dessus que
n'est que les que l'extrême droite du
monde entier si je puis dire à fait de
v2 poutine son héros un bon aujourd'hui
à senlis il s'en distancie parce
qu'évidemment l'ukraine c'est quelque
chose quand même pas très bien donc mais
quand même n'oublions pas que dans l'est
et dans les airs dans les années qu'on
parle des précédentes je vais dire des
dix dernières années poutine était
considéré comme le le croisé de
l'occident qui allait de
rétablir la série un petit peu derrière
mais à côté car c'en est un et les
marchés à propos de dénazification qui
aident poutine à faire passer ça dans
l'esprit du peuple sait que des
notifications égale la grande victoire
oui du 9 mai 1945 qui est la plus grande
victoire de la totalité de toute
l'histoire
on a écrasé l'allemagne où c'est devenu
une super puissance mondiale puis
nucléaire donc cette grande victoire
elle a été obtenue contre le nazisme
donc ça anobli la cause et la paresse la
la mémoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale c'est ça la vraie rose et saint
aujourd'hui en russie un processus que
le saiss orthodoxe que c'est justifié ça
fait trente années des années sinon des
décennies c'est ça qu'on nous bassine le
peuple russe avec des films de guerre
les avec avec cinq victoires - ce qui
fait oublier que la russie de staline a
signé un traité avec l'allemagne nazie
bah c'est que ça très abondant ainsi
comme ça on n'en parle plus et le pacte
germano-soviétique ce qui fut l'unique
38 collègue
monsieur s'il n'y a pas tout à fait la
même chose ensuite je vous paie pas
attendez vous pouvez pas comparer munich
38 et et le pacte germano-soviétique
trentenaire 39 41 s'est passé là ça
c'est du révisionnisme historique non je
suis désolé la nanon beneo comme c'est
exact oui non mais si je voulais en
fait c'est ce disent qu est-ce que ces
pardons la défense du traditionalisme
russe face au modernisme de l'occident
oui effectivement ce qui dit là est
important parce que vladimir poutine
nous fait miroiter le grand remplacement
qu'on entend dans les discours aussi
français en ce moment mais sur un autre
thème expliqué qu' ethniques mais lui
fait miroiter le grand remplacement des
valeurs traditionnelles russes
conservatrice par les valeurs décadente
occidentale et moi lorsque je parle à
des rues certains me disent si on ne
fait pas la guerre en ukraine demain on
aura des gays qui vont venir faire des
gay pride sur la place rouge donc c'est
vous dire la confusion de toutes les
valeurs je voudrais dire que aussi que
et réagir par rapport à ce qui a été dit
c'est à dire qu'il ne soit il ne s'agit
pas seulement pour les émirs poutine de
blanchir ou de justifier son opération
1000 spécialistes air en ukraine il
s'agit de raconter une histoire de cette
guerre qui est celle d'une d'un
renouveau d'une nouvelle guerre contre
les nazis et on voit la mise en scène
qui est fait par la propagande russe de
ce lâche qui fuit comme ils ont fui à
l'époque devant la grande armée de
staline et aujourd'hui on est exactement
dans cette guerre sainte comme vous le
disiez c'est vrai que c'est une vraie
religion aujourd'hui la grande victoire
des rudes et des russes des soviétiques
de larmes de la grande armée de staline
ce qui permet au passage de aussi de
réhabiliter staline et de dire que les
victimes étaient tués un dommage
collatéral de l'industrialisation qui a
permis de mener à cette victoire et mais
en réalité la culture russe à l'étranger
chez nous en europe même aux états unis
n'est pas plus menacé que l'est
russophone d'ukraine que dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure avant que
vladimir poutine ne s'en mêle et
n'importe quel ukrainien vous dira je
parle sous votre contrôle que avant 2004
2014 avant que vladimir poutine annexe
la crimée et ne déstabilise l'ukraine
suite à cette révolution pro-occidentale
de maidan dont il s'est senti menacé
dans son dans sa vision civilisationnel
de l'empiré russe et bien avant cela il
créneau phone russophone tout ça il
vivait très bien il n'y avait aucun
problème par la force géographique
certaines régions étaient davantage
russophone que créneau phone mais tout
le monde parlait russe tout le monde eut
créé par les ukrainiens tout le monde
s'entendait très bien il n'y avait
absolument aucun problème à ce niveau
important de l'histoire pour en revenir
justement à cette grande russie à
christian ma carrière je me tourne vers
vous parce que est ce que justement on
parle d'une d'une guerre sainte on a vu
que cette guerre alors vous parliez
justement de l'église orthodoxe est
soutenu par le patriarche kirill qui est
donc le patriarche de moscou qui lui
justifie l'invasion de l'ukraine il en
fait une guerre morale pour la
préservation des valeurs morales donc on
va voir ces images d'ailleurs qui date
du 14 juin 2020 c'est la consécration de
la cathédrale des armées on va et
d'ailleurs y voir vladimir poutine est
en compagnie du patriarche ensuite un
peu plus tard d'après ce que j'ai lu le
discours de ce fameux patriarche kirill
le 6 mars 2022 en pleine guerre
d'ukraine c'est un dimanche de la saint
jean et il dit lui il a célébré la
divine liturgie dans la cathédrale du
christ sauveur à moscou où il a prononcé
un sermon enflammé pour justifier les
causes de guerre il endosse en fait le
discours de navires poutine il ya même
des tonalités faut dire apocalyptique
dans son discours donc est ce que c'est
parce qu'une guerre sainte dont on parle
non d'abord le concept de guerre sainte
n'existe pas
dans l'orthodoxie donc je crois qu'il
faut pas salir l'orthodoxie au passage
c'est le patriarche kirill qui se permet
ce genre de chose ensuite poutine fait
une guerre littéralement préventive en
ukraine puisqu'il ya pas eu d'agression
de l'ukraine à l'égard de la russie ce
qui est strictement interdit par la
théologie orthodoxe donc deuxième
violent de la théologie par par kirill
et puis pour finir kirill c'est un
officier du kgb qui s'appelle good jeff
d'eau d'origine
ces images à l'arrière boutique
une très jolie datcha dans le nord à
côté non loin de celle de poutine les
deux hommes ont l'habitude de prendre
des bains ensemble d'aller à la chasse
ou à la cueillette aux champignons c'est
pas du tout le personnage qu'on voit là
sur les images ce sont des saints a fait
un faux-pas trianon c'est un véritable
oligarques en soutane c'est un oligarque
il a fait de l'église une olargues une
oligarchie supplémentaires il ya un
conseil de que deux une quarantaine de
ligue arc autour de poutine lui c'est le
41e et il s'est enrichi à titre
personnel on considère d'après des sites
sérieux qu'il a acquis jusqu'à 2
milliards de dollars à titre personnel
et qu'il a fait porter sa part des
prête-noms de sa famille donc sonné à
tous les cousins du patriarche qui sont
dans toute une série de holding c'est
absolument incroyable et du coup il ya
une fracture dans le monde utilisent une
idéologie mais à l'époque du 10ème
siècle qui oppose déjà ce qu'on appelle
les slavophile qui sont favorables à un
courant unique de l'histoire russe
messianique les russes auraient une une
fonction unique dans l'humanité et
occidentaliste c'est à dire des gens qui
doivent moderniser la russie et cette
fusion
cette compétition permanente entre
sanofi dit occidental occidentalo phoebe
et bien le patriarche kirill la
transformer uniquement al'avantage de la
save ofili cder que pour lui la russie a
une mission quasiment charismatique qui
est de civiliser autrement que par le
marché c'est le mot qui l'emploie le
supermarché la consommation et je le
cite les fausses liberté qui sont
cultivés un occident au souvenait que le
régime communiste qualifier les libertés
de l'occident de liberté bourgeoise donc
fausse tandis que les vraies libertés
c'était celle de rien avoir à manger
halal est donc on sent bien qu'il ya
problème de discours tient ce discours
de ses valeurs cette défense des
malheurs de conservatrice à oleg kotov
sur quelques mois de dire quand même que
l'ailé slavophile se retournant dans
leur tombe en henry vous avez le
discours de jésus du patriarche et oui
je suis d'accord mais c'est d'une cdu il
réduit
l'idéologie slavophile a qu'elle qui
étaient délaissées à vos fils qui était
d'ailleurs des européens leur journal
s'appelait l'européen dans les étages
tout à fait haut ou vers l'europe il a
réduit sa main une vulgate absolument
épouvantable qui qui n'a de même que
si vous la wilaya autant la théologie et
il a vidé je dirais l'institution
ecclésiale russe de toute réelle
théologie il en a fait comme poutine de
new york 6 mme parisot juste un chiffre
nous tous qui faisait réellement les
représenter pour le patriarcat de moscou
40 % de ces paroisses si 40% des
paroisses
fonds scission et parce qu'elles ont
fait les gars sont une lueur
% et 40 % sont déjà passés au patriarcat
autocéphale de kiev ça veut dire que
kirill portera une responsabilité qui
est la suivante deux points ce sera le
premier patriarche de l'église russe qui
aura réduit l'église russe de 40 % de
ses effectifs et de ses fidèles
autrement dit c'est le destructeur le
dynamiteur de l'église russe qui est né
en 988 dans le fleuve dniepr par le
baptême
dudu du tsar celles qui portaient pas le
titre de sa race duo du prince vladimir
et de tout le peuple de kiev kiis qui
est entré en aube blanche dans l'eau à
travers une image absolument vous dis
fils christian c'est un imposteur grosso
modo pour faire court j'étais sonné
jeudi comme la phrase de staline quand
on lui a dit on un problème pour trouver
un patriarche il a dit trouver moi
fonctionnaires du parti qui ressemble à
un homme de dieu mais se mutinent
l'utiliserai dans la cathédrale des airs
de staline c'est une hérésie totale un
maître un bon faudrait savoir si ces
drames alors comment rappelle juste tout
bêtement un camp en urss la religion
était proscrite les traîtres été
déportés et pas un seul homme a fait
tant de mal à qui que ce que joseph
staline
l'idéologie incroyablement hybride qu'on
est en train de voir enfin que c'est
tout et son contraire
c'est complètement symbolisée par cette
cette chapelle des des forces armées qui
est d'ailleurs architecture mans de nos
regards généralement tuera le mans s'est
abstenu normand effrayant de voir une
église noire déjà et nous trouver la
recette c'est la chapelle qui voulaient
dei de l'aumônerie de des forces armées
il ya plein de symboles communistes ya
plein de ils ont effectivement ils ont
quand même sous la pression de certains
fidèles ils ont enlevé les mosaïques de
staline et de sympathie après tout
d'autres représentations blasphématoire
mais il ya plein de des toiles rouges de
essayer de marquer
tout ce qu'on a dit il faut dire quelque
chose de très important et voici la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'un pays mais il
faut bien qu'un une tente le patriarche
kirill et poutine sont en froid et ils
ont des rapports d en
[Musique]
mai
je peux vous le dire au micro juste un
mot justement pour lutter un peu ce
sujet de la religion thierry wolton mois
d'après ce que j'ai lu poutine lui écrit
les russes les ukrainiens les
biélorusses sont unis par une langue le
pouvoir des princes de la dynastie hors
ue wicked et une foi orthodoxe donc
c'est vraiment ça qu'ils défendent
l'annuaire poutine oui on l'a déjà les
plus depuis le début il faut il faut
préciser une chose si excusez ma cape a
été dit mais qu'est ce qui me paraît
important pour comprendre je sais mais
ça peut-être pas plaire à mon voisin
ici compagne
n'oublions pas que dans l'orthodoxie il
est près de songer l'un des
fonctionnaires de l'état et sont payés
donc ils sont pas vraiment les simples
promeneurs toxico 6 à être pas mal on a
dépensé des poires ça dépend où en grèce
oui en russie oui le oui bah oui mais
c'était beaucoup cette une belgique
aussi à
pierre le grand oui quand il a situé le
saint synode pour assujettir l'église
c'est exact vous avez raison mais sa
date que de pierre le grand et en amont
et en aval en
1998 pardonnez moi sur ma carrière
aujourd'hui une orthodoxie donc
ukrainienne
alors très important très important vous
dites les paroisses sont en train de
passer alors certains prêtres de
paroisse sont carrément en train de
passer dans l'église ukrainienne
indépendante qui a été reconnue par le
patriarche de constantinople à aimer ce
qu'il faut aussi dire c'est que le
métropolite onu qui est le numéro un
placé par le patriarcat de moscou à kiev
lui-même et il ya le premier jour de la
guerre il a il a donné l'accord laquelle
une lettre quand même accusant cette
agression d'être le crime de cas un
contrat belle et la lettre ne s'arrête
la lettre continue ainsi et on se
demande si lui aussi ne va pas
finalement passé se réconcilier avec
ceux qui se sont séparé de lui phoceis
ici carrément toute l'église ukrainienne
seldon uvre du mode de metropolit onu
frn oncle quand même c'est le presque le
numéro 2 de toute l'église orthodoxe
russe ou ukrainienne sert le patriarcat
de moscou on se demande si lui aussi ne
va pas passer dans l'autre camp car les
moines les moines du monastère des
cavernes a qui arrivent il faut dire
avec la prononciation ukrainienne bien
que ça soit imprononçable en français ou
en anglais ou dans toute autre langue
occidentale mais enfin ils sont en train
de s'armer ils ont ils ont mis des
vestes pare-balles des casques et se
sont armés pour deux endroits bien que
stérile et un peu soheil seul dans ce
soutien à vladimir poutine et les
marchés il me fait
ça passe ça peut paraître un peu
anecdotique mais et on entend ce que
vous dites sur la guerre sainte moi j'ai
toutes ces images parce qu'il ya
énormément de kozak qui comparaissent et
ico des deux côtés un mais côté russe
c'est une véritable institution ils sont
je crois 40000 dans le temps dans les
régions sud au début ils ont participé à
l'annexion de la crimée ils ont beaucoup
combattu dans le nombre et à chaque
opération de combat moi je les ai
beaucoup suivi et à chaque opération de
combat vous aviez un prêtre qui venaient
les bénir et eux pour eux dans l'ordre
dans leur esprit il se justifier parce
qu'ils avaient besoin aussi de se
trouver une cause ans parce qu'on
l'appelle qui sont pas exactement du bon
connaît cela mais il était heureux
vraiment non oui non moi ça me rassure
et ça me rappelle les l'inra par les
soudards en bosnie qui était athée en
1989 et qui a mis dans les débuts des
années 90 se colle un dieu dieu est avec
nous ce n'est ni bogue sur le sur leur
casque mois pour moi ils avaient tous
nos conversations en fait sur
l'idéologie ces idéologies sont
cosmétiques elles sont obtenues ces sas
meetic mais c'est justement au bsr ça
s'est rappelé justification de cette
guerre ça sert à recruter
le soutien du public de même que trump
ne croyait pas un mot tu as toutes les
idéologies qui footing n'est pas
religieux d'ailleurs n'en poutine fait
mine d'être je suis poli il multiplie
les actes il prend même le bandeau
glacée pour le nouvel an orthodoxe et
c'est ce à quoi il se signale mais même
le ministre de la guerre autre officier
du kgb qui n'est pas militaire de
formation lui aussi on pourrait en
parler ne cesse de se signer donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
particulier il faut comprendre que quand
l'urss s'est fondée en 1991 il n'y a que
deux institutions qui restent debout
lesquels l'une s'appelle le kgb qui va
devenir le fsb et l'autre s'appelle
l'église b ou églises et donc l'église
va servir de blanchisserie idéologique à
tous ceux qui avaient persécutés
l'église précisément qui avait sonné
l'athéisme il y avait fait exploser les
charges réelles oui par exemple le
christ sauveur c'était une piscine
publique qui avait été la cathédrale
christ sauveur a été reconstruite après
payet latine mais staline l'avait fait
raser 1935 oui absolument
donc tous à l'église à à une jambe et un
désir de revanche on a réhabilité
nicolas ne renoncerai avec celle de
vladimir poutine le
nationalisme est allé malheureusement de
pair avec ça c'est à dire que puisque le
communisme ne tenait plus le peuple
russe et qu' il était discrédité on a
remplacé le communisme pour faire très
court par le nationalisme et l'église a
servi en partie la hiérarchie en tout
cas le patriarche de moscou a servi cet
événement et vladimir poutine avait
absolument besoin de trouver un ciment
pour
avoir l'adhésion de son peuple lorsqu'il
est revenu au pouvoir en 2012 et je vais
poursuivre ce que vous disiez avec cette
cathédrale de crise un sauveur parce que
qu'est-ce qui a marqué son virage
autoritaire c'est cette performance des
pussy riots on s'en souvient en 2012 à
laquelle rural de crise un sondage il
suffit d'une fusion ce flou qu'est-ce
qui s'est ensuivie il s'est en civil
suivi une salve de lois liberticides d'
atteinte aux sentiments religieux des
croyants d'interdiction de la propagande
homosexuelle parmi les et c est la
religion à ce moment-là a servi de
fondement finalement et de justification
au virage répressifs et autoritaires de
vladimir poutine qui disait à ce moment
là puisque l'on atteint à nos moeurs
traditionnels russes conservatrice
orthodoxe et c est bien vous tous les
opposants toute cette nouvelle vague
avant garde qui avait soif de liberté
qui avaient soif d'émancipation et
l'autre finalement grand passé
soviétique on veut aujourd'hui
reconstituer et c'est là où la religion
et le communisme se rejoignent alors
qu'apparemment ils sont complètement
antagoniste c'est que les deux ont servi
la cause de vladimir poutine qui était
finalement de diviser la saleté pour
mieux régner entre les conservateurs et
les programmes s'allumant d'accord il ya
eu d'accord on élire en signe des deux
mains dommage que je n'aie pas 4 je
signerai encore plus juste un point
c'est à partir des pussy riot que
poutine s'est disputée et que le froid
s'est installé avec kirill le patriarche
vous entendre le français d'accord parce
que le burida ça m'intéresse ça fait un
petit moment à reprocher à kirill
d'avoir instrumentalisé fait monter
cette affaire de pussy riot parce que
les pussy riot en fait c'était moque et
non pas de la religion tant que ça elle
s'était moqué du patriarche kirill et il
a eu un contact il a pris ça comme un
compte à régler personnel alors il a
entraîné le pouvoir civil dans cette
cause ce qui a agacé poutine le froid a
commencé comme ça le froid a commencé
comme ça mon fils l'a bien utiliser
vladimir poutine pour justement
justifier sa guerre on va justement
parlez maintenant du peuple russe
poutine qui a déclaré d'ailleurs lors de
l'annexion de la crimée donc en 2014 que
la société russe n'avait jamais été
aussi unis dont il l'a dit à l'époque la
société russe derrière lui alors on va
regarder votre reportage justement lna
elena volochine avec ce témoignage d'un
moscovite finalement assez représentatif
d'une grande partie de la population
russe
[Musique]
retraités alexandre au pc course et pour
ce qui est des prix rien n'est plus
comme avant on trouve des mots meilleurs
ce qui m'a étonné c'est le prix de ces
poivrons
277 euros le kilo sauf sûrement pour des
légumes c'est un bris foule
depuis l'invasion de l'ukraine et la
dégringolade du rouble l'inflation est
galopante
alors comme tout les russes alexandre
doit s'adapter
le jus de fruits par exemple je ne peux
pas prendre celui qui fait envie je dois
chercher des articles en réduction
pour l'aider à relativiser alexandre
peut compter sur les chaînes de la
télévision russe
vous voyez le monde entier est en
déficit il n'y a pas que chez nous que
les prix augmentent
parfois alexandre sans qu'on ne lui dit
pas tout
je me dis que probablement c'est vrai
parce qu'on dirait que c'est vrai
vraiment on dirait mais en même temps on
ne dirait pas du tout mais alors pas du
tout mais on ne peut pas l'exclure non
plus que même si on ne dirait peut-être
par il est possible que ce soit vrai
mais lorsqu'il entend certains messages
de propagande alexandre doute vraiment
une attaque de l'ukraine quand la crimée
j'en doute ils savent que ça aurait été
une guerre ouverte avec la russie
pourtant alexandre soutient son pays et
son président voit les sommes accusés
poutine de tous les maux c'est comme
acquise et ce talent il semble que tout
se passait le cours politique et
historique qui les a forcé à prendre de
telles décisions il n'avait pas le choix
comprenez moi bien je suis russe et je
vois mal comment je pourrais ne pas
soutenir mon pays je peux être critique
ou ne pas l'aimer mais dans une telle
situation je dois le soutenir c'est
comme une épouse une bonne épouse peut
penser que son mari a raison ou non mais
dans tous les cas elle doit se tenir à
ses côtés pour recharger ses munitions
alexandre porte ce trait de caractère
plus que jamais vitale pour les russes
la résignation
ils sont résignés donc à les russes
elena on parlait donc de les imaginer
tout ce qu'ils ont dû subir ils sont
complètement résigné et comme je dis pas
plus que jamais maintenant ils sont en
guerre ils doivent adhérer ceux qui
n'ont pas le choix de partir parce
qu'elle a acquis par papy sankara qui
partent mais pour aller dans le sens du
reportage et des propos de l'ena
volochine la prix nobel souhaite l'anah
alexievitch bilan russe qui est
biélorusse qui n'est pas le craignait
n'est pas ce qui est bien le russe
écrit que malheureusement dans une
interview qu'elle a donnée dans un
joueur américain en 2014 elle est
consternée de voir que la majorité de la
population russe applaudi à ce que les
rues sont en train de faire dans le dos
de basse là ça se passe en 2014 elle
écrit aussi dans son livre que pour le
peuple russe assez pour expliquer la
réaction de ce monsieur combien de voix
vives vive la fin de l'urss comme des
drames eu une humiliation ce qu'on peut
comprendre mais la deuxième partie est
encore plus gênantes y vivent
l'occidentalisation
comme une humiliation
c'est à dire le supermarché la carte de
crédit le point de retrait bancaire ce
sont des instruments que kirill va
facilement par exemple diaboliser en
disant que le test d'adhésion aux idées
démocratique libéral de l'ouest c'est la
gay pride voilà ce qu'il a dit lahm au
pommeau donc c'est quand même très très
con cernant d'entendre ce discours là
83% des russes approuvent l'action de la
lumière pour wigan même 12 points de
popularité c'est selon l'institut russe
indépendamment indépendant levada
parce que ça vous et moi j'ai les normes
et
bada c'est très serré même si très
sérieuse donc ça veut dire qu'il a
encore plus populaire qu'au début de la
will harries test une popularité de
façade et c'est une popularité de
surface et le directeur l'ancien
directeur maintenant directeur était
fatigué mes lev goudkov las le
sociologue en chef de ce centre nous
l'expliquer c'est à dire que ce n'est
pas une adhésion de conviction les
russes ne sont pas fondamentalement il m
vladimir poutine en réalité il y avait
cette séquence formidable d'un type qui
avait accroché un portrait de poutine
dans un ascenseur est filmé la réaction
des gens les russes n'aiment pas poutine
simplement comme ils sont forcés de
vivre dans un système ils n'ont pas
d'aspirations à quelque chose qu'ils
n'ont pas connue c'est à dire la
démocratie
donc ils sont enfermés ils tournent en
vase clos et leur esprit tourne aussi en
vase clos notamment avec l'interdiction
des médias indépendants et avec la
propagande qu'ils sont forcés d'absorber
et donc c'est une adhésion qui en fait
je dis il n'y a pas de liberté
d'expression d'accord il n'y a pas de
liberté de la presse d'accord mais il
n'y a pas de liberté de pensée en russie
c'est là que ça commence c'est à dire
que les gens lorsqu'ils font siens le
message officiel c'est parce qu'on leur
a absolument annihiler tout jugement
critique toute possibilité et tout
finalement perspective de si jamais ils
disent qu'ils n'adhèrent pas vladimir
poutine quel autre choix ils ont qu'ils
peuvent t'ils à voir quelles
alternatives selon elle avoir aucune
alors c'est pour éviter de devenir fou
et de se retrouver malheureux dans un
système on peut pas vivre en état ce cas
ces recherches est ce que c'est vrai ma
désastre télévision ce qui se passe dans
la société russe comme le dit à la
philosophe fédrigo renew d'un un
désastre pour la sociéré faisons le
désert s'il a pas commencé avec guti il
a commencé depuis et très longtemps je
dirais il s'est accentué sous le
communisme ce que je pense qu'il est
très important ce qui a été dit à
l'heure c'est que il faut c'est vraiment
l'incompréhension d'ailleurs souvent
entre l'est et l'ouest si je peux le
lien entre la mentalité de l'est et de
l'ouest j'élargis un tout petit peu par
rapport aux pays d'europe centrale et
orientale aussi de ce côté-là ont connu
le communisme ap au moins fortement et
un peu moins longtemps que l'union
circuler que le peuple russe mais il
faut savoir quand même que ils ont
appris beaucoup sur la tête beaucoup
beaucoup sur la tête et que cette espèce
de résignation dont on vient voir
illustration dans ce reportage est
quelque chose de très très fort et donc
nous n'arrivent pas à comprendre parce
que d'abord on s'est toujours des
intérêts cette histoire est ce que c'est
moi de six cantons fermer les yeux de
pendant très longtemps sur ce drame y
compris new soviétique et europe
centrale donc si vous voulez on n'a pas
voulu savoir et aujourd'hui on veut les
intégrer forcément je parle là de
l'europe orientale et centrale et
orientale et on n'accepte pas qu'il ait
des différences nationaliste et c'est
tout ça est une grande incompréhension
alors ça n'excuse pas j'entends bien ça
n'excuse pas ce qui a été dit à l'écran
par ce parce russe
excuse pas non plus la meilleure poutine
mais c'est à mon avis un de la part des
occidentaux un manque de compréhension
des choses et s'il y avait la meilleure
compréhension je pense qu'on aurait
évité pas forcément et poutine parce
qu'il est enfermé dans son dans une
idéologie mais en tout cas en ce qui
concerne d'autres pays qui sortent du
communisme je pense à la hongrie par
exemple je pense à la pologne par
exemple eh bien je pense qu'on a réussi
à éviter beaucoup de maisons de
malentendus voilà malentendu christian
ma carrière parce qu'on arrive à la fin
de cette émission s'il perd la guerre
cette grande russie ça va rester un voeu
pieux s'est alors comment peut-il sortir
de la guerre il va changer ses buts de
guerre qu'est ce qui va justifier si
effectivement et bien il ne parvient pas
à priori l'armée en tout cas l'armée
russe en ce moment s'enlise ga stéphanie
on s'est trompé assez largement sur le
commencement de la guerre il s'agirait
de ne pas se tromper sur
la fin à supposer que ça va ce que ça se
passe comme ça car ce n'est pas mon avis
je ne pense pas que un soir il va y
avoir un traité
cessez-le-feu et que tout va s'arrêter
je ne le crois pas une seconde je crois
qu'on va assister comme la russie et
l'urss avant elle a su le faire à des
conflits gelé ou pas d'ailleurs déconfit
brûlant plutôt parce que l'expression
est très déplacé à une sorte
d'agitation contrôle et aux bordures le
dôme basse va permettre s'il est
entièrement aval et non pas les deux
républiques séparatistes
mais les deux oblast c'est-à-dire un
territoire beaucoup plus vaste la
descente vers la toute la bordure de la
zone de la mer d'azov avec mario paul
qui n'existe plus belgian sq et jusqu'à
odessa non inclus parce que c'est pas
nécessaire à ce moment-là zor est une
mère russe à 100% déjà il a fait fermer
le détroit de kertch par un pont il ya
quelques années on le sait tous et de la
zorn à la caspienne il ya un canal qui
passe par le don donc vous avez un arc
absolument stratégique absolument
essentiel et moi je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention parce que ici en
occident nous avons une mentalité
philosophique qui est fondée sur le
gagnant gagnant nous faisons nord stream
2 les russes y gagne et nous on y gagne
on est gagnant gagnant sauf que poutine
a une mentalité perdant perdant
j'ai perdu donc vous les musiques autour
de vous allez perdre et il a montré la
diarrhée oui merci
donc c'est tendre u600 qualité
perdant-perdant fait qu'il n'y aura pas
de points d'arrêt stop claire et nette
de cette guerre et c'est bien le plus
dramatique puisque mais la grande aoc
restera et il faut une autre avantage
marais vendent russie restera dans les
limbes à un fantasme qui hélas
continuera à faire à faire bouger les
foules mais poutine aura un problème
gigantesque c'est celui qui s'annonce
avec les militaires poutine est un flic
et de bas niveau c'est pas habilités
vrai et c'est un faiseur de fiches de
compromettent pour compromettre des gens
sur les vies privées c'est comme ça
qu'il a fait carrière ce n'est pas chef
de guerre tout comme staline d'ailleurs
qui était un épouvantable le jeu de
guerre ou très mauvais donc il va avoir
un problème parce qu'il a fait humide il
est quand même la glorieuse et puissante
1 0 évoquer les généraux qui sont
abattus par les ukrainiens c'est quand
même pas tout à fait glory il va falloir
qu'à un moment où l'autre y répondre de
tout cela devant l'institution militaire
la preuve c'est que choïgou semble-t-il
a déjà des ennuis et des soucis
c'est un autre conclusion je je pense
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup discuté
idéologie mais je pense que quand vous
avez des langues cette émission la
grande russie ainsi que je voulais même
conclu le 10 mai mais je pense que il ya
quelque chose de beaucoup plus important
dans les motivations de poutine qui
n'est pas seul et des siloviki c'est à
dire les flics comme popo pour faire
simple qui sont autour de lui la
motivation vous l'avez très bien dit
c'est cet amour de laon où il n'y a pas
de gagnant voilà c'est la véritable
idéologie c'est ça c'est l'éducation
qu'ils ont reçus dans les écoles du kgb
merci beaucoup à vous lègue comme chef
d'avoir été avec nous merci thierry
wolton merci christian makarian merci
bien sûr à elena volochine merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi et puis vous
restez avec nous un sur france 24
[Musique]